gang just want to remind you that the ru
garbage comedy special is on our youtube
page right now it is it is our favorite
moments from last year's tour and
speaking of doors we're here to announce
2022 the middle class famous store baby
new cities new trash new money yeah gang
we're coming to hartford albany syracuse
atlanta tampa orlando pittsburgh buffalo
detroit denver phoenix salt lake city
chicago rosemont and this is just part
one plenty of cities coming after that
it's live stand up live auig it's a good
time get your tickets now we'll see you
there welcome to another exciting
edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's favorite new
podcast this is are you garbage sure is
it's a little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find it out
there girl to be classy or if they're
just a big old piece of trash i'm your
host h fully coming at you on a
beautiful day down here at anthony's
basement yeah she's upstairs past that
on the couch why
i don't know just this okay sometimes
she takes a breather jesus is great i
thought there was going to be a kid
she's going to have to hide jinx every
week
sometimes she just chills i fell asleep
watching the news i don't know what do
you want she's back on the nyquil i
don't know what to tell you all right my
co-host is coming at you from right next
to me he is the ceo of ru garbage he's
international businessman let me tell
you something folks the next time you
reach for a best pal do yourself a favor
and make it a kippy give it up for kevin
james ryan oh bringing back the classics
what's up everybody thanks for tuning in
as always please make sure you rate view
subscribe on itunes full video available
on youtube and as you know those numbers
are true the roof cooking baby and then
obviously there was something else we do
in the intro do you remember what it is
talking about patreon.com patreon.com
the greatest website of all time check
it the [ __ ] out uh slash ru garbage you
sign up you get bonus content episodes
of ayg episodes of hard feelings which
are completely different podcasts live
streams the whole nine yards check it
the [ __ ] out beautiful and make sure you
check out the special specials on
youtube check it out on youtube and
speaking of the special how about a nice
quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man makes us
all look good we're on 4k now because of
this guy oh [ __ ] i don't know what it is
but it's pretty cool give it up for
t-bone mcmuffin toby mcmullen what up
dudes
yeah i made the switch to 4k i had to
literally pull up two videos and be like
this is what it looked like before this
is what it looks like yeah and i was
looking at him i'm like all right we can
do it
still looks the same to me
[Laughter]
but gang we could not be more excited to
have our incredibly special guest here
with us today for the first time he is a
very funny very successful stand-up
comedian and podcaster he is the host of
the amazing podcast have a word but the
big question everybody's mind today is
he garbage i believe he hails from
liverpool i mean
that that this could be the shortest
episode
we're done that's where smoke stacks
were invented
give it up for adam rowe everybody
thanks for having us here boys uh yeah
any of your british listeners or anyone
from america who's spent any time in the
place like they've had my accent
immediately and they've got this we can
just shut this down now i wanted to ask
wrap it up that's like the boston accent
yeah yeah i wanted to ask you that no i
you know i'm an actor oh god
theoretically
so he's not a director relax now i
should i should know this but what is
the difference but there's multiple
accents in england
there's the there's a nice sounding one
yeah
and then there's this yeah yeah yeah
what's huge and then you yeah
so what happened was so every time i
come here every time i speak to any
comic they're always like oh you are you
irish you're scottish that's all we got
cause what happened was
ireland sent a lot of people over to
england and the first port you hit is
liverpool so a load of irish guys [ __ ]
our great grandmothers yeah we did
and a couple of hundred years later you
end up with me that's the difference
yeah
i thought it was like the like it does
have more of like a brogue like cockney
is do you speak is that what it is is it
cockney no that's like barney will be in
rubble or you know
cockney's london cockney is london trash
cockney is london
cockney is like idris elba before he
came over the air okay oh really and and
spruced himself up so why does hugh
grant talk the way he does is it because
he's more refined i think his agents
told him it'll be beneficial
you're going to america they think we
all sound like this you need to really
lean into that yeah yeah yeah yeah damn
all right that's funny yeah i was
curious about that
we i should know it there's so many like
we so the city right next to liverpool
is manchester and everyone thinks that
accent's very different it's not
manchester's just slower so liverpool's
like you know right it's quite sharp
manchester sounds like a stoned scouser
it's the same it's just slower but
people in like the hierarchy in england
they all have the hellos uh they all
they have like that like the high
british yeah yeah but like
you've got to understand are they all
lying
like you they they're so far removed
from what i am yeah exactly yeah
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
what
like it's not even it's it's not even
apples and oranges it's it's apples and
t-bone steaks
[Laughter]
it's such a different thing
all right give us the scoop what's
what's what's the full adam row
backstory how'd you grow up so where'd
you grow up i grew up on a council
estate in
in liverpool so a council of states is i
would say a ghetto okay okay
it's just people who look and sound like
me okay and i add one little brother is
it government it's like government
housing yeah okay yeah so it's all
terraced houses
hit the jackpot here boys
i didn't know you were coming in like
that when's your flight back we're going
to need a couple episodes i think
she was throwing rocks at cops at age
nine i like it
this is how [ __ ] my street was right
every house on my street had an
extension built on the back and that
extension was the bathroom because what
clearly happened was they built the
entire estate and was like we forgot to
put the [ __ ] toilets in it
damn yeah so we're talking like billy
elliot hardcore billy elliott is perfect
so billy elliot is newcastle which is
essentially like it's a twin town middle
of the field they're the same place
there's just a slightly different accent
that's it that's [ __ ] but they're the
same thing like billy elliot's dad could
be my dad
and if i wasn't a comic i'd be ballet
dancing
it's close
i want to get ooh
what did your mom and dad do so my mom
drank
so did mine
professionally
and my dad was a painter okay
like a house planer yeah so he would and
occasionally he'd get a job with the
firm and that would be a corporate job
and he'd paint like a shopping center
but then a couple of months later he was
back painting houses and my mum
my mum in years before i was born so
before i was born she was a care worker
for like
uh people who had special needs sure
okay and then she cleaned it up she got
injured in a hospital operation and she
got nerve damage in her leg and then she
did nothing but then she worked in a
fruit and veg shop but didn't tell
anyone officially that was happening uh
so like off camera yeah yeah still
collecting i like it yeah for her i like
that and then i would work in there at
christmas time when people bought more
vegetables because that's where i'm from
people bought more vegetables
because it was like it's the holidays
sprouts
that's we we drink for the cucumbers
around christmas we were just talking
about this if you ever work
with your family where they don't know
the company where they don't own the
company that's a tough look i was in the
back i wasn't like if you're both if you
and your mom are unloading boxes
together that's a bad look oh it's worse
than that i was like taking lunch
together so i was like 11 12 years old
jesus christ what the [ __ ] what'd you
grow up in the 20s what the [ __ ]
i think i was washing i was washing
dishes at 12. i was probably 12 was my
first job one day a week though like a
saturday two shifts in the back room my
mum would be
peeling and chopping up carrots and
swede and turnover and i would bag it
like we were basically doing really low
level drug dealing
like she was cutting i was bagging and
nothing your shirts off yeah yeah
they don't trust you
but i have to be in the back because
obviously if anyone walks you've seen a
child working there sure then the fruit
shop would get shut down really you
can't have that damn god damn that's
[ __ ] hardcore holy [ __ ] and you have
your younger brother yeah
all right
gee what was school like
it was okay i went to an all boys
catholic high school did you now you
guys have to pay for those over there
are they free no no they're all free
they're free yeah so these are the
uniform and everything yeah so we're
yeah and so it's like billy elliot we
had an all boys catholic high school and
then there was a a path which is about
12 yards
long and then on the other side of that
path was an all gales
catholic high school right and what they
they were like we can't have
boys and girls mixing together a
teenager because they'll all be [ __ ]
each other so what they did was they
they starved us of that attention that
made it worse and then at 3 p.m every
day released us all on twitter at once
yeah and that path seen some fingering
like down the years plenty of it i'm
listening
where was this path out exactly
he jumped up internet on google maps and
on the path is a nunnery
like there's a nuns comment on the path
huh wow man we are in it already yeah
um
what did a vacation look like growing up
was there one
so i
yeah
my vacation as a kid so i went on one
abroad vacation when i was four but it
wasn't with me mum and dad it was with
an auntie and uncle
[Laughter]
going on someone else's vacation
the freshmen it's like the fresh prince
of liverpool yeah
my auntie got with the guy and he
ordered the other son got with a guy
that's that's not that's not falling in
love got with the guy did they live in
the same same community that you guys
lived in uh not far from maybe like four
or five miles away same kind of housing
though
yeah and why were you guys in the
government housing
your dad just wasn't making enough yeah
it's just that's very common in in
working class parts of england okay is
just even people
people buy them
so you get government housing and if you
live in them for like 10 years plus you
have like the right to buy it okay so
there's a lot of like former council
estates uh in in the north west of
england for example that used to be
entirely governments owned and now
they've gone right you're poor but now
you're okay and yeah
i mean you have to be doing do you have
to be doing really really well to have
like a a single standing house over
there
the size of houses that
people who are doing well over here get
compared to what we get is insane really
for the price like that the housing
market as far as i'm aware in the us is
so much better than in the uk really
like
a three-bedroom house in
liverpool in a nice area you're looking
at
four hundred thousand pounds
pounds ain't nothing to play with either
that's heavy yeah i just got caught up
in those euros and liverpool's cheap
yeah like london
london's like worse than it's like worse
than new york yeah yeah yeah i know
comics who live in so i i still rent my
house at the minute and it's it's as
cheap as you can so i've got a
three-bedroom house with a garage
and it's that's where you live now you
yeah all right so me and sam live in a
three-bedroom house nice damn you got a
three-bedroom house yeah not the patreon
shouts out
i love this local working-class boy
makes good that's the show patreon is
the
life-changing
medicine website dude we literally i
mean we devote episodes to sam yam and
jack conte the two developers of patreon
the two founders of it stanford grads
yeah good kids tell you that right now i
that that house costs me 600 pounds a
month like there's comics i know living
in like a six bedroom house share in
london playing treble after a room for
the room yeah and there's no benefit to
it well that's that's good there's
there's no benefit to living in london
like london is two hours away on the
train so when my age when i signed my
ages a few years ago he's like do you
want to move to london and i was like no
and he's like oh well what if i need you
yeah and i was like are you ever going
to get me a tv job with more than with
less than two hours notice that's just
not listen the camera's rolling you
gotta get here
i'll be there don't worry we'll figure
it out they want you to play spider-man
but you gotta be here in 15 minutes
i told you you should have moved
are your parents still in
the same place so as i say my mum drank
and she doesn't drink any more and
that's not because she stopped
she shushed away she passed away the ale
took her and my dad
nails jesus christ it's cold as ice over
here
oh that's like something a sailor would
say i know
again dock workers [ __ ] the ale took me
mother and the fever took me brother
but you know what that's what they say
about wolves in alaska right now they
was taken by wolves
you know what's so [ __ ] up on which a
dirtbag i am when you said a i was like
i could go for an ipa yeah i bet yeah i
was like well that's d8 it sounded it
sounded refreshing
and i know the answer is garbage so i
live
one and a half
blocks away essentially from my dad but
you got your own spot yeah you're
killing but i live so close gotcha which
i think like in my opinion that if this
was a british podcast and i was hosting
the are you garbage british version are
you rubbish yeah are you are you a piece
of [ __ ] it'd be called that living that
close to your parents after you've moved
out is oh no that's for sure garbage
here yeah as well yeah yeah yeah that's
totally i like it though but if you have
kids and stuff like that it's very cozy
yeah well the the idea for me is like
you what i think you want to be close
enough to your parents that you can go
around whenever you want but far enough
away that they can't come around without
asking you first yeah and that's getting
like that because uh
show up it's it no it's not that it's
you know we do live too close but he's
got bad legs so it's actually hard
even though it's up hill so even those
two streets that's hard for him to do
now so
i i have to go and pick him up in my car
because i've never heard that medical
term badly
what exactly is that
got to set a man
that's what the doctor told them they
were like we don't know what's going on
but this is wrong yeah
this isn't supposed to get bad legs
[ __ ] up
damn so what's his situation now he's
still he's still painting and working no
no no he's long past that so uh when me
mum died when the ale took her he sort
of took the bat on and now he likes a
drink as well man
he's like you know she will not have
died in vain yeah i will finish i will
carry your family name on yeah
maybe a [ __ ] novel or something
[ __ ] angela's ashes
i was going to ask you if you had a
garage fridge but i guess not no do we
have a fridge in the garage
now do you have a garage now yeah but it
does really
it doesn't function out you couldn't put
a car in it but it's just filled with
[ __ ] yeah yeah
that's most garages i have a cupboard
that leaks
that's what the garage is it's a
cupboard that leaks like you can't put a
card in it it's it's stuff that i put i
put stuff in there that i'm like i will
take that to the tip
and then i don't yeah yeah yeah what's
the tip like the the dump yeah it's a
good one tip i like it is the
refrigerator in your house do you have a
full-size one or you have one of those
little child's refrigerators like you
guys no i i have a full size so it's a
fridge on top of the bottom what's up
it's a fridge on top freezer
down the bottom
so it's open up and then there's trays
yeah it's nice
that's real classy dishwasher
no my ex-girlfriend took that and i've
never replaced it
i'm sorry she took the dishwasher so
when i broke up with my ex i was like
look
it's pretty spiteful yeah for the
listener his current girlfriend is
sitting on the couch
she's holding the washing machine
i'm taking the stove
jesus christ well these guys don't play
over there when i when i broke up with
me x it was me doing the breaking up and
i i wanted to be like a nice guy so i
was like look this isn't working anymore
we need i was not a [ __ ] game show
you don't give her a household appliance
i didn't tell i didn't wanted to take
that what i said was take a couple
records and some paintings take as long
as you need i was like i'm gonna go and
stay in my cousin's house for like a
week you figured out what you need to
figure out and then we'll sort it out
and when i got back she'd already left
oh the copper's gone
no windows
want all the wiring out of the house
here's here's a follow-up question what
kind of dishwasher can you take out like
that okay so this is probably trash you
do you i know i i know what you're
talking about desktop one so like it
goes above desktop it's not a computer
yeah it's a desktop dishwasher it's
about it's about the size of this stereo
you've got here it's like a microwave
yeah it's a microwave you can wash one
dish
holy [ __ ] dude oh man that's [ __ ]
awesome
now i get why you're asking about the
the fridge you thought it was going to
be like a three-quarter i've seen those
the europeans go smaller on a lot of the
household appliances super common is the
small fridge yeah wow yeah what kind of
car are you driving over there i've got
a kia sportage
i'm a key man myself look at that yeah
i'm trying not to be anymore
i got two years left on this lease and
i got an email from the car dealer that
i bought it off the other day going do
you want to upgrade that like you could
probably upgrade it like now and i'm
like yeah i think i think four sorry
it's me birthday next week and as a
present to myself i think i'm gonna
upgrade the car that's great yeah i love
that you have to get another key or can
you get something else no i can get sort
of it's a it's a multi so it's a random
deal you lease it
no it's not quite a lease it's a sort of
finance deal where they're like we'll
sort of pay off the rest of it with the
part of the finance for your next car
gotcha they're probably looking for the
used car yeah these cars are yeah
because they're right everybody's
looking for used cars now yeah i want a
range rover but apparently they're not
good
the [ __ ] liverpool meet so just
kidding
[Applause]
yeah but they they break down a lot
especially here you're [ __ ] because
all it's all it's it's imported yeah so
apparently also i can't afford one
let's put that on record patreon.com
and help we can yeah they're not they're
not good over long distances apparently
which is [ __ ] annoying because
they're called range rovers like that's
what it should be good at but apparently
they're really great at inner city
driving but like if you try and take it
on the motorway for too long it'll just
it wants a break
i'm out is the key automatic or is it a
stick [ __ ] it's a stick everything's
sticking yeah rocket over there i like
it
i want i want automatic that's gonna be
the the next car will be automatic i to
know something
it's a running diesel does it yeah it
does yeah you guys are still on diesel
europeans are crazy dude it's so much
cheaper it is it's cheaper i don't care
about the environment
he's burning two engines let's go
i just want to get from here to there in
the least amount of money possible
diesel
kip let's talk about hellofresh
hellofresh
we love them man loving them hello fresh
boys and gals pre-portioned
saves you time
delicious meals right to your door so my
girl still talks about the shrimp that
we had
fantastic they're not they don't skimp
on the portions either i'll tell you
that right now yeah you're not leaving
hungry no nice they take care of it
that's why it's america's number one
meal kit you know that numero uno numero
top of the charts uh cuts back on time
spent in the kitchen so you can spend it
uh with your other resolutions this year
uh meals running around 30 minutes or
less plus quick and easy meals including
20 minute recipes low prep easy clean up
options provide an even faster route to
putting food on the table and don't
forget dessert they got you satisfy your
sweet tooth with seasonal limited time
goodies like dunkaroo cookie dough or
vanilla delight cheesecake hey we're a
dunkaroos corporation over here uh yeah
they sent they sent them both to us
i feel like i feel like a professional
cooking there i'm ramsey i'm everybody
somebody you know what the big christmas
present was for my parents this year
what's that subscription to hello
friends hello fresh got him straightened
out over there go to hellofresh.com
garbage16 and use the code garbage16 for
up to 16 free meals and three free gifts
look at that hellofresh.com garbage16
use the promo code garbage 16 for up to
16 meals and three free gifts do it kip
let's talk about ladder love ladder
uncertain times
want to make sure the family's taken
care of a lot of times it can be
difficult term life insurance all that
kind of stuff ladder makes it easy
you got to get on there got to take care
of it ladder is 100 digital no doctors
no needles no paperwork when you apply
for 30 million in coverage or less three
mil yes well i mean
that ain't nothing to put your nose up
what
all you need is i'll die twice all you
need is a few minutes a phone or a
laptop to apply uh ladder smart
algorithms work in real time to find out
if you're instantly approved uh if you
prefer to talk to a person which you can
instead of talking to robots whatever of
course you know you covered they got you
covered and uh some people like that
they like to hear a voice on the
internet of course maybe maybe you got a
free day you want to call up talk hey
how's your day doing best thing about it
they're licensed agents they don't work
on commissions so they're not going to
try to upsell you look it out for you
they're going to help you
uh issued um
ladder policies are issued by insurers
with long proven histories of paying
claims they are a and a plus rated by am
best don't know what that is but it's
got to be good sounds cool um finally
since life insurance costs more as you
age now is the time to cross it off your
list so go to ladderlife.com
garbage today to see if you're instantly
approved that's ladder
l-a-d-d-e-r-life.com
garbage ladderlife.com garbage do it
what's your brother do
uh he currently works on scaffolding so
like i put the scaffolding up and how
much younger was he four years four
years okay so he's in his mid-20s yeah
he's 26. nice night you guys get along
yeah quite well okay he's a fuck-up
like he is a fuck-up yeah but he's a
fuck-up that is quite adorable okay like
he [ __ ] up and he's like oh [ __ ] up
again you're like yeah yeah yeah yeah
you're looking at two of them yeah
come and stay in my house for two weeks
until
dad lets you go back
he still lives with me
yeah yeah okay yeah that's good and
that's really good for both of them sure
they've both got someone there exactly
to drink with
i'm telling you man you guys have to
battle you guys can say what you want
but if i had my way i'd love to have my
parents [ __ ] two blocks down
really yeah
yes there's only two friends in the
world
my best friends
they're watching right now hey buddy
um sports growing up yeah would you play
football just
soccer sucker right yeah uh yeah
football and
we'd play rounders as well which is
essentially british baseball we don't
really have baseball in the uk so
we
play a game we call rounders which is
essentially you throw me the ball i hit
it and i try and do a lap of the field
before you get the ball back it's
baseball okay all right around us
um i wouldn't play rugby i've never been
interested in it i love the nfl now
really yeah i love watching it we're
going to the knicks game today really
yeah yes that's right we're gonna watch
the basketball in a bit
um do you have a favorite
nfl team do you follow have you picked
one
a few years ago when i was trying to get
into the nfl someone said to me just
pick a team i thought like trying out
for a team
if only i'd moved to london
i would have got it and yeah the nfl is
making a big push in london or in
england played a couple games over there
i think the if the pandemic hadn't hit
when it did i think in the by 2025 there
might be the the jaguars might be a
london-based team but i think that's
gonna be re-thought now because getting
teams over here for the games would be
too problematic
but i i don't follow i tried to follow a
team and i've tried so
much to do it so a few years ago i made
someone who's into it he was like just
pick a team
doesn't matter who because if they're
[ __ ] now they'll be good in four years
and whatever so i picked the eagles
because yeah
because i was watching
it's always sunny at the time like while
i was having the conversation that was
on the tv and i was like well i'll pick
them
and then you're not gonna like this but
someone said oh
eagles fans are all [ __ ] do not be an
eagles fan i totally agree
i couldn't agree your friend steered
you're right yeah and then i went to one
of the london games a couple years ago i
went to the rams verse the bengals so i
was like well i'll just pick one of
these teams to follow so i picked the
rams okay but then i just i'm such a big
liverpool fan like it affects my mood if
we lose i'm in the moon for a couple of
days we win i feel great for a few days
and i just couldn't find a way to have
that emotion yeah that's that's about an
american team yeah it's like boring
so i just try and enjoy the game now
yeah watch every game i don't care who
wins i just want the game to be good if
someone's losing i want them to win yeah
i'm the same way with sports like that
yeah that i'm not fully into big
liverpool fan yeah been a lot of games
as many as i can any soccer riots in
your history
no i don't really get the idea of
fighting over
a team
like no brawls no green street hooligan
type thing going on never
killed a guy after a match
i nearly got it i nearly got beaten up
when we played a team called leeds
so i it was a cup game maybe 10 years
ago maybe a little bit longer and we
just won and we where the the stadium is
in leeds there's quite a bit of a walk
back to the away fans car park where the
coaches are to take you home
and we got about 100 yards from the car
park and i'm with two of my friends
we're all like 18 19. and one of them
goes i'm never coming back to leeds it's
such a [ __ ] oh a dump it sounds like a
rough part of town
there was about 40 guys that we just
hadn't seen or heard
30 yards behind us and they were like i
just pictured them dipton behind you
all right
back here again and they wanted to kill
us and we were so lucky because they
were the lead that
wit football in the uk they're crazy
you're crazy about it they are but
there's there's sort of like a rule
where you only fight with people who
want to fight about it be a gentleman
about it so they'll they'll arrange meet
ups yeah like green street they will
arrange we meet here often
and we fight this is still going on yeah
and we'd sort of happen to be in that
fight
so we were very very lucky
that there happened to be another 50
liverpool fans who heard what was going
on and we managed to get away and then
they all had the fight they all wanted
really but we were seconds away from
being beaten to it in the end of our
lives jesus
sounds like a
what's the car park situation why are
you gonna take a bus there
it's a couple of hours away
does that you don't say you know so you
can drive if you want you could drive
you wanted to but it's sort of like it's
part of the experience of going to an
away game is getting on the coach with
50 of the liverpool fans and you all get
drunken and the party starts like yeah
at [ __ ] seven in the morning yeah
yeah and foley at those games like the
the home team and the away team have
different entrances at the opposite side
i've seen all the videos [ __ ] crazy
yeah you'll occasionally
like so like in liverpool there's
another team called everton and
occasionally at a liverpool everton game
you'll see like two or three liverpool
shirts in the other end because they've
gone like
there's brothers who would support
different teachers sure yeah so
occasionally you'll get it at a very
local derby but it's very rare
man
it's [ __ ] hardcore yeah that is
hardcore i don't understand how it goes
on out here when there's like an nfl
game and there's literally oh you will
just sit wherever your ticket is well i
don't know how people don't die every
week
i mean they're they get they get pretty
stupid sometimes but it's like it's
three on three or one on one it's not
[ __ ] 80 on 80 in the middle of the
[ __ ] game
[Laughter]
all right for the halftime show
no one sets the stadium on fire that's
crazy
pretty cool though
start setting up those smoke grenades
[Laughter]
um
growing up yeah your mom cook
yeah she did yeah specialties
jack and coke
vodka diet coke
is a drinker but she was thin
was that it was that her drink vodka
holy [ __ ] yeah she'd do a bottle of day
70 cl
a vodka a day holy damn [ __ ] what uh
what's your dad drink now uh whiskey
like scotch whiskey and full falco
what's up what coke coke what'd you call
it oh [ __ ] fat coke full [ __ ]
you're fat foley that's [ __ ]
fantastic
give me a fat coke that's awesome so
what should cook because me and t-bone
were talking about this on the way in
yeah about the cuisine
especially around breakfast the beans
thing came up in the car okay what's the
beans thing did they have beans at
breakfast yeah but we
you've got to keep it separate
he got very defensive he's gonna [ __ ]
hit you
it's gonna be like a liverpool match in
here
beans are great as long as they don't
touch the egg
you need to keep the beans in
or is that a you rule it
it's it's a commonly accepted rule that
is too often broken
and i won't stand for it yeah
like if i go to a breakfast place and
they don't separate the beans from
everything else
a dish right right if they don't do that
the tip gets cut in half immediately
it's like you don't know what you're
doing this is wrong this is against the
rules uh-huh yeah so i
breakfast yeah mean one would do what
would it be classic what so two fried
eggs four pieces of bacon
two sausages couple of hash browns
as much toast as you can fit in the
toaster that's all right that's [ __ ]
strange
beans in a pot
coffee or tea
um i drink tea in the house and coffee
when i'm out and that's always been the
case so if i might have drank tea my
whole life
there's something so refined even from
this dirt bag i'm going home
and being like cup of tea please like i
just go there's something in your roots
where you are classic a little bit it's
really nice too because i'm trying to
switch over because the coffee's been
giving me bad anxiety like later on in
the day it's not your parents
it's the coffee
but we had tea a lot with you know
growing up you know a little tea little
sugar yeah you know a little milk real
nice yeah so what do you do english
breakfast what are you doing english
breakfast today up until about three
years ago i would have two heaped spoons
of sugar and milk yeah yeah but now i
don't have the sugar yeah i've stopped
the sugar i don't have sugar in me
coffee either that and a couple slices
of toast ain't too shabby so when you're
sicky-wicky on toast i i don't think
there's a i've said this before i don't
think there's a food in the world
for any part of a meal that isn't
improved by bacon
100
like a cheesecake is better with
bacon what's crazy is you're 100 right i
was going to say they've really pushed
the envelope in the last 10 years
putting bacon on sweets they do it on
donuts over here it's a big yeah yeah
yeah cause it's like the sweet and sweet
salt and salty and sweet yeah i got so
pissed about that because i never
remember i don't remember discovering
like even like uh if you get like
chocolate with a little sea salt on it
kippy likes that yeah it's [ __ ]
phenomenal yeah why the [ __ ] weren't we
doing that the whole time i just found
out about this like two weeks ago it's
crazy
i think it's because putting salt on
chocolate
is just so insane like it's great
oh it absolutely works but chocolate is
so bad for you already
obviously i eat as much as it as i
possibly have time for but it is so bad
for you already but i think maybe years
ago someone and i'm gonna put salt on
that and someone went whoa whoa whoa
whoa let's wait a couple of hundred
years kids bonkers what are you doing uh
talking food are you a brown sauce guy
oh it depends brown sauce with bacon
what's brown sauce yeah what are you
sneaking that in what have you been on
listen you've been you've been to
england before i get it this guy has a
[ __ ] fish and chips once all of a
sudden he's [ __ ] you don't know what
brown sauce is no hp sauce yeah oh yeah
it's hp sauce i've got to be honest with
you i said a couple different kinds of
them right yeah different like flavors
mmm they're all just brown sauce flavor
mm-hmm that's slightly like a green
bottle or red bottle so the the there's
a fruity one that's the green bottle
yeah that's what you're thinking of yeah
just don't touch that don't give that to
like
don't don't give that to you
it's more of a leeds thing um but yeah
hp source is the original brown sauce
and then there's loads of different
brands that now did their own brown
sauce and i got really incredulous then
what you guys like you don't know what
brown sauce is but to be honest with you
neither do i
[Laughter]
we have something similar it's called
heinz 57 sauce right
yeah which is very similar to it
that's is that not tomato sauce no they
make no it has it they do have a vert
like i think it's called heinz 57 sauce
it is it is and it's like a bread it is
like a it is like that brown yes because
we use the one restaurant i used to work
at we had hp ish
t-bone's pulling your card right now
mine yeah not really oh god i mean is it
brown is it a sauce it [ __ ] qualifies
[ __ ] winston churchill yeah relax
all the pictures i look at it's red
what
i'm saying that it tastes the same
i've tasted both of them they're both
similar i think that was like our
attempt at hp sauce brownies with bacon
red sauce with sausage
that's my morning that's my real yeah
that's pretty good so if i have a
sausage on toast you do those blood
sausages
blood sausages yeah
they're cooked watermelons well no
they're like ripe like blood sausage
right what you don't know what that is
no i do i just wanted to leave your hand
maybe oh that's what you mean yay black
pudding fried pig's blood pig's blood
and rice or whatever they put in there
it's just fr it's it's he said fried
pig's blood didn't know what i meant
when i said blood sausage
oh you mean fried pig's blood because it
looks more like a it said there's
what's the
sausage on toast that would just be
normal sausage yeah like links yeah you
put it on
make a sandwich yeah sausage sandwich
there you go
i'm in here
sandwich no not just sausage and hp
sauce
wow i didn't grow up on the docks
i had a [ __ ] bacon egg and cheese
like a gentleman yeah
yeah the u.s it's a bit yeah to not have
to have your a breakfast sandwich
would have egg and cheese on it now
that's at least
that wasn't breakfast every day for you
growing up like it's going no
cereal yeah cornflakes cornflakes yeah
that's normal and then on a weekend
sunday
saturday so yeah you get that yeah all
right sunday before the roast dinner
okay before the wine the roast roast
yeah the roast it would be a roast
always every sunday a roast yeah so like
that she'd make like a joint of beef and
roast potatoes vegetables was that good
was she she could cook yeah yeah yeah a
specialty i think you asked me before
um
sage and onion stuffed pork ribs okay so
she would get a rack of pork ribs
fill it with sage and stuff and roll it
and roast it for like 10 hours
and
just
sounds pretty clear to me that's pretty
classy and the breakfast on paper you
would think
but it sounds nice
plus the tea
i don't know
kit's all right
no he's not
sure trash
[Laughter]
don't let a pot roast fool you all right
this is what happens he gets food on the
mind he goes ah these are all right
no no no
we would also
on the food thing i can i suppose the
trashiest thing i would eat
on maybe a once every two week basis
sure you know she knows what i'm about
to say she would chop up a red onion
spread it around a plate it's a bedstorm
cover it in cheese okay melt it in the
microwave and then i would just eat the
cheese and onion off the plate
that's not that bad
it's not man it's not what are you
talking about and mix i'm not saying
you're not gonna like it sure you're the
but it's trashy
microwaved raw [ __ ] onions and cheese
if you have like some chips or like a
piece of bread or something yeah but i
didn't
you're you're describing nachos yeah
nachos are good
he's eating raw vegetables
and cheese well mcsorley's does that the
bar here in new york they put cheese and
onions out yeah sure that's all yeah
i'm sure there's also some guy puking in
the corner so it's a little i mean
[Laughter]
kev what do you know about babel babble
babble or i would say libba bill bebel
because i speak a little french you do
and i tell you what what i could have
used babel you were heading down over
there huh it's very nice you want to
learn a new language easiest simplest
way to do it absolutely fantastic yes
babel is uh at the top of the list when
it comes to uh learning a new language
with an app that sold over 10 million
subscriptions a lot of people doing this
they know what they're doing right now
they know what they're doing it's 15
minute lessons that make a perfect way
to learn a new language on the go other
language learning apps use ai for their
lessons plans but babel lessons were
created by over a hundred language
experts i've used it when i was trying
to learn german and talk to my wife yeah
i don't like that ai
i used other ones they had me saying
like i'm a little girl and stuff like
that i'm like
i'm a little teacup
short and style um the teaching methods
have been scientifically proven to be
effective with babel you can choose from
14 different languages including spanish
french italian german go french go
deutsch
um plus
plus babel speech recognition technology
helps you improve your pronunciation of
your accent so you're not sounding like
a hillbilly when you're over there you
know what i mean walking around with a
little bit of clays we got a hell of a
football team too
right now when you purchase a
three-month babble subscription you'll
get an additional three months for free
look at that look at that six prices
that's six months for the price of three
practically pays for itself yeah just go
to babel.com use promo code garbage
that's babble b-a-b-b-e-l-com
code garbage babble language for life
got three words for you what's that
helix yeah helix
helix
you know why helix is the best why
because you're not waiting around in
some [ __ ] mattress store kicking the
tires on some guy with a [ __ ] tie
with stains on it and a short sleeve
button down looking for a sail just got
divorced living out by the air pulling
coffee breath oh on his last leg short
sleeve short sleeve button up too the
toughest look there billboard
you don't want to be buying a mattress
from drew carey here what you want to do
is you want to go over to helix
you want to take the quiz take the quiz
they were they were lucky enough to uh
send me me and my me my lady and
mattress big man didn't get one you got
to throw that in my face every time yeah
they pay us to
um where's mine we took the two minute
sleep quiz uh we got la we got matched
with the twilight matt i got the
twilight mattress here i gotta tell you
game changer first adult mattress we
loved it so much we we we just bumped up
to the king size crazy yeah it was
fantastic he'll uh take the two minute
quiz it'll match you with the perfect
mattress just for you
everybody's unique you have soft medium
firm mattresses mattresses cool you down
if you sleep hot great for spinal
alignment if you're a big man they got
helix plus for you plus size sleepers
uh so if you're looking just head over
to helixsleep.com
garbage take the two minute quiz i'll
match you with the customized mattress
give you the best sleep of your life ten
year warranty you try it out for a
hundred nights risk free uh they'll even
pick it up if you don't love it but i'm
telling you you get the kippy approval
you will helix is offering up to 200 off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
for our listeners at helix sleep.com
garbage one more time helix sleep.com
garbage now back to the show
all right you want to do some questions
we got to do some questions some
properties
yeah
um
what were the pets like growing up
okay
so um
i had a budgie a what a bed a little
budgie oh
bird people are bad people right would
it fly around the house or was it in a
cage it was in a cage where it would be
allowed around the living room sort of
once a day it was like taking it for a
walk
let the budgie out for its walk
i would have never pegged you as a bird
is the budgie the name of the bird or
the kind of bird that it is that's the
kind of bed it was called the name of
the bed was sparks that was his name
and and it was yet the breed of bed is a
budgie and here's the awful thing about
sounds trashy dude it does sounds like
you just grabbed the pigeon outside yeah
so i came back from school one day i
think i was like five years old right
and me mum goes to me and got some
really bad news sparks has flew away
right
and she goes but
he must have wanted to say goodbye to
her because he he's he's come back and
left this feather on the doorstep and
she gave me this heather and i treasured
this feather for years i was like sparks
flew away but brought me back this
and i remember i was about 16 years old
11 12 years later
you believed it that whole time yeah
i've seen until this moment right so i'm
in the house with like my two best
friends and we're just talking i mean
mum by this point is full-blown drinker
she's on air like the second half of the
vodka and diaco
and we're talking about um
me beard with me and me two best mates
and like what happened and i was like
yeah he flew away flew away
he flew back and he left me a feather
and they were like you're a [ __ ]
idiot
and i went mum didn't sparks fly away
and come back in this feather and she
went nope
so the sip of a drink went what happened
was sparks uh pulled all of his own
feathers out and killed himself and
that's just the story we told you so you
didn't cry oh my god
did the bird really kill itself the bed
killed itself
i had a suicidal butcher that's crazy
dude
what dude i've never heard of a pet
committing suicide yeah the long way too
pulling out its feathers not even flying
into a wall
he took his time
take a hot bath with a cold razor or
something will you jesus christ holy
[ __ ] dude
the what i mean to believe that and to
be like come back from school the birds
are hanging
swinging back
sparks was here
i also had a rabbit that [ __ ] itself to
death
i had a rabbit that was it it couldn't
ship properly and the [ __ ] was clogging
up its [ __ ]
and then an indoor outdoor wrap was an
indoor rabbit
yeah well people have like a pen out you
keep like a pen outside wait it was
indoor yeah it was indoors
because i've only ever seen them in the
outdoors i was not with these people
we're talking about the roses i couldn't
sleep
in the house i wouldn't like that it
smells like a pet store yeah shout out
on your face while you're sleeping oh my
gosh jesus no dogs cats we had a dog for
a little bit so he got into drugs
i was gonna say
how did he get it
cutting with the bookies
at the house on liverpool they didn't
cover that shank down at the wharf uh we
had to give the dog away because it was
destroying the house because it was this
was at the time my mum worked in the
fruit shop so we'd be at school all day
my dad the mum and dad split up and yeah
the dog was in the house on its own it
was just destroying everything because
we were leaving too long on its own so
we have to give it away
no pet wanted to sleep
you hear the rabbit talking to the dog
you hear about sparks
i'm just gonna [ __ ] myself
i'm gonna squeeze my [ __ ] together
really tight i'm gonna act crazy till
they get rid of me
dog's walking around talking to himself
holy [ __ ] man
damn
that is something else let's talk about
now a little bit
okay trying to class it up a little bit
you pee in the shower
yeah okay
do you brush your teeth in the shower no
okay are you like staunchly against it
no i'm not against it i just don't i
sometimes will brush my teeth while i'm
[ __ ] yikes that's not good but why
will you be [ __ ] and then decide to
brush your teeth and be brushing your
teeth like i got a [ __ ] that one okay
that's a little more of an emergency
i'll give you that
and i have definitely got ibs yeah
doctors never told me but it would be a
short conversation yeah yeah yeah
irritable bowel syndrome yeah
i got it too yeah it's bad sometimes i
have it's like the fuse is lit and it's
like i gotta get to wherever i gotta get
too close i eat kfc i can literally set
a 47 minute timer
specifically 47 minutes and i'm gonna
yeah
is that your go-to fast food over there
no
chinese
takeaway chinese take like is is more i
will eat that like twice a week
sometimes really yeah huh mcdonald's
burger king yeah burger king not so much
okay big king i think is subpar it's
yeah that's the that's the bottom
i would go
mcdonald's and kfc sort of on a level
and then kfc is right down the bottom
okay yeah kfc is like expensive
service station so if i've done if i've
been performing a few hours away from
home on the way home i'll stop to get
like petrol for the car
and or petrol that's
that's cliff
i gotta give him a point for that yeah
said petrol all right so he's negative
99.
i think he can do it in the next 15
minutes do you brush your teeth in the
shower never
i do when i'm taking a dump
i just feel like i'm saving time pushing
my teeth while i'm done i'm like no it's
not good man that's not good otherwise
it's just time you're not getting back
you might as well combine
your schedule can't be that tight
old school um do you know how to tie a
tie
yeah okay yeah actually every day for
sure okay okay that makes sense you uh
right now
if you had to you got a suit at the
house you can throw on
uh yeah multiple ones yeah i've got one
with me
no one with me
what's going on to a nice dinner yeah
we're going fine dining on sunday
whereas i i don't know where we're going
okay but they specifically say on the
website the gentleman has to wear a
dinner jacket and uh they would prefer a
suit and tie okay nice pretty good
all right pretty good
yeah i see on instagram negative 98.
you're you're pretty put together all
right
fashion wise was that always the case or
now that you started making a couple of
bucks you're like i can afford my dress
entertainment is significantly better
towards the end of my 20s sure 100
percent and that's a combination of
having a bit more money and also just
realizing what a uh idiot i used to
dress of course of course i used to wear
t-shirts that would say like sex drugs
and rock and roll oh my god
one of them said sex drugs and sausage
rolls one of them said drink triple c
double act single i used to gig in that
t-shirt oh my god dude
that's bad
not any novelty t-shirt is not good no
do you wear pajamas
no like proper pajamas no i will wear
the t-shirts i've had on all day oh my
underwear
and sliders
that's my pajamas oh you don't sleep
with the sliders on do you no i sleep
just in the underwear okay just in the
underwear do you put you the sliders you
mean they're
uh
slippers yeah you have those right next
to the bed yeah so you
you put those on when you get up
most of the time
that's pretty pretty good that's all
right i gotta get out of it yeah but
it's a liverpool house it's broken
glasses
you're stepping on a dead bunny if you
didn't
all the rabbit [ __ ]
all the rabid [ __ ] and bird feathers
everywhere
are you a shoes off in the house
no and i think anyone who is that that
proud about their house i don't want to
be in your house
i don't disagree with it new york's a
little different because new york is a
very dirty city so like your apartment
you kind of got to because there's like
bum [ __ ] everywhere but yeah
but if i turn up at any of my friend's
house like especially if they still have
a home and they're like they're like our
mum wants the shoes off i'm like let's
just i'll wait outside yeah
and then we'll go come here
going over someone's house i don't like
taking my shoes off yeah yeah like i'm
not walking around i feel like you lose
your power a little bit oh i'll tell you
hey it turns out you turn into a child
again yeah i take the shoes off i'll
take my shoes off in the house yeah once
i'm settled yeah yeah i'll often take my
socks off and put my sliders on
that was a great sense take these socks
off and put me sliders
yeah uh okay all right uh do you hang
your t-shirts or do you fold them
i fold my t-shirts okay all right i
hanged my shirt [ __ ] yeah
okay what's the cable situation at the
house
tv channel wise what do you got
got everything including the sports but
not the movies because there's enough
movies on netflix and okay is it
satellite or is it cable it's cable sky
or something isn't the virgin media
branson company
i upgraded to the maximum internet in
the first covert lockdown because i
needed it to do my podcast okay
and i can't not have the sports channels
because liverpool but i don't pay for
the hd channels i've just got the
standard oh
my god no hd no i've got hd like on some
of them but the sport channels they
charge you like an extra 80 pounds a
month for it to be hd so i'm like i'll
just watch it in standard definition i'm
used to watching it on some foreign
stream on my laptop with some arabic
guys shouting about the game so i'm
quite happy for it to just be like 720p
on the tv
every game looks like the 86 world cup
[ __ ]
at the hotel you're in now will you use
the or any hotel will you use the safe
yes
really i just use the safe
first time i mean you were i mean yeah
we were friends we put our passports in
there passports in the safe laptop in
the safe cash in the safe
really damn you're rolling around that
thick
there's like 500
like i'm not leaving it in the hotel
room when there's a safe there why would
i not put it in
i'm already using it
like i'm already like why would i if i'm
putting the laptop and the passport
on the table yeah that makes sense
realize everything's cheaper over here
for him for him yeah that's awesome it's
like when we go to like taiwan or
whatever you know what i mean
i don't know why
that's got to be a good feeling
everything's cheaper
it's not really like what you
like
mean
by
everything's
new york yeah well i was like nine
dollars i've been paying for beers he's
pissed it's not liverpool yeah that's
not if he was coming from london
that's not [ __ ] normal by the way
nine dollars for for a three for a 12
ounce beer
like that in liverpool that's four
pounds which is like three dollars but i
noticed if i spent 160 bucks over there
it would it would be they would take two
different accounts
who is
well you guys aren't on the euro they're
on the phone
they never switched over that was thing
we're not switching over and the pound
always stayed stronger than the euro
what until
then and then it went through the floor
yeah
that's pretty bold though i like that
yeah tough kids you used to get two
dollars for a pound
like when i was a kid i always knew that
you would get two dollars for every
pound you spend you don't get it's about
one to one now roughly
yes
yes slightly more so i think we we when
we went we went to a restaurant called
frank for dinner the night we arrived
and
it was a hundred and forty dollars for
the meal and the drinks and that was
about 105 pounds
okay all right yeah yeah so not not too
far off
yeah i like all right um are you
currently in a fight or a beef argument
with a neighbor
is there someone where you're like [ __ ]
you terry everything you know or like
it's not spoken
it's more of a cold war a yeah
there's this oh actually there's there's
two silence
there's two silent wars so the next door
neighbor guy passively from war
no never going to russia in the winter
this kid's like chamberlain the next
door guy will passive aggressively like
move my bins to where he wants them to
be oh i don't like that i'm on your side
i [ __ ] freaked out don't touch my
[ __ ] yeah no i mean i i will have left
the bins out four days longer
there's a house over the way from us
and the the people who've just moved
into the house been empty since i've
moved in they've started using
mine and sam's parking spots
but they're not like officially ours but
they're [ __ ] ours like they are ours
it's a very philly thing yeah
yeah that's my spot i need like i'm
coming back and you're in it or like
they block me in like so the way it is
there's blocking ins that's that's nuts
there's there's space for eight cars
right it's just like a big patch that is
as being come to use a car park for the
people on australia sure
and
everybody parks in the same place has
been parking in the same places yeah and
there's so the four in front can't get
out if anyone's behind them so what
happens is my girlfriend will park here
and i will park right behind her because
then i can go and let it out
or if i'm asleep she can go and take the
key and let herself out and whatever but
i've started parking like there and they
will park behind me and block me in oh
[ __ ] that man yeah you got to say
something yeah we've sort of been like
you do know that there are and they're
like oh well we're they're so they're
they've just bought the house so they're
decorating it they're doing it all uh so
they're like leaving it they're like oh
we're only going to be five minutes
we'll eventually park on our pocket it's
just the easier phenomenon yeah but it's
not easier because every time you do it
we have to get you to move it yeah
exactly yeah [ __ ] that what's the other
beef
he's moving me bendy yeah he's moving
moving your pins that's right he's
moving me
i got really petty a while back as well
so
they they were doing housework at like
eight o'clock in the morning like
banging and nailing and all that sort of
and drilling and like i'm a comma i'm
sometimes not until three o'clock in the
morning
and i was like so annoyed so i wait
because they've got young kids as well i
waited till i knew the kids were being
bad and i blasted the hamilton
soundtrack as loud as i could for the
entire thing i don't mind that you got
to get back keeping it classy though i
like it yeah bro you made noise while i
was asleep now i'm going to make noise
while you want to be sure
uh the kids in the middle can you play
chess yes
like would you consider yourself okay
like decent yeah i can play yeah okay
that's pretty good all right i was in
the chess club at school oh really yeah
big reader you read no i've made a new
year's resolution to try and read one
block every two weeks and if i read two
for two
yeah you're not gonna do it no
buddy no how many times all right so
it's currently
the first week of january how much have
you read so i've brought a book with me
i have a book that i've been taking on
vacation with me for like two years i've
never [ __ ] opened it once yeah i
bought this book two years ago and i've
never got around to opening it crazy
what is the book malcolm gladwell
outliers oh i just uh i just uh did that
yeah i did an audio version is it where
freedom
you're looking for an outfit
well kippy said it's not that good to
begin with
yeah it's all right
do the audio books
i want not bad i i won't do an audiobook
i've been doing them either i've been
doing them in the car it's all right see
i might be able to do that if i was i
could maybe do it in the car that's the
only time i put a podcast on i haven't
got the attention span to sit and listen
to something if i've got anything else
going on yeah it needs to be visual for
me as well but obviously if i'm driving
you can't have like a [ __ ] film on
while you're driving yeah yeah yeah
all right um have you ever bought the
floor model of like an appliance or a tv
what what's the floor the model would be
like you're at the electronics store and
you're like i've got a couple of dings
i'll take this one like don't give me
one in a box
give me this one oh no okay no no no no
no no no that cause it'll be like 50 you
know 50 bucks less for the tv i know
people that have done that with sneakers
and one's faded off
barbecue sauce on it and [ __ ]
so in a i will ask for discounts if they
try and give me that one
of course
like this is yours you'd be like well
yeah you got to knock somebody yeah yeah
so if they're like oh there's only one
side one in your size left it's the the
display is that okay i'm like no unless
you knock yeah not 20 bucks off yeah
yeah you can see that
you fish
no
i did once when i was a kid ever fish
off a bridge no
all right pretty good
any instruments hanging on the wall at
your house no
um no my dad once put a guitar on the
wall and no one in the house plays it
i don't know where he got it from uh-huh
i don't know why he has it
but i came home this is when i lived
with him i was like why is there a
guitar on the wall and his answer was
sometimes people have guitars on the
wall
that is
the trashiest thing i've ever heard
because it's usually somebody showing
off that they play guitar
for your dad to put a guitar on the wall
and nobody in the family plays it that
is [ __ ] legendary no one's even ever
took a guitar lesson question was an
acoustic or electric it was acoustic and
this is the worst bit there was no
strings on i knew you were gonna say
that i
knew gonna
it was a stringless acoustic guitar hung
on the wall man and his explanation was
sometimes people have guitars on the
wall where was that your any extended
family living around you
uh cousins or anything so the ants were
not to the animals
okay so that was those guys oh yeah what
about the end we didn't really talk
about that i don't think we ever got to
the vacation to be honest with you we
can go to that i just went they she met
a guy he had a son she didn't so i was
taken sort of as hair's son so that his
son had someone to play with on the
holiday when they wanted to [ __ ] do
it yeah are they still together yeah and
now they've got two kids of their own ah
okay there you go love stories
to answer what you just asked where not
that ant but where i grew up so on my
street was me mom with my dad the next
street was my dad's sister her husband
and the hair four kids
the next street up was his other sister
and her
four kids three from a previous
relationship and the one from the guy
she lived in the house with and my
granddad lived around the corner as well
man you're not coming back from that
you're like you guys are like ticks yeah
i don't care how much tea you're
drinking
you're not coming back
do you guys all get together at holidays
and all that kind of stuff everybody's
together no we get together when one of
us gets married or does
okay is there any like parent beefs
where like aunt whoever doesn't talk to
uncle steve or whatever again it's all
very silent so it's never
so my god
my dad with his sisters is sort of like
i don't like her for this reason because
then if they see each other they're like
sure sure sure okay all right
that's very british i would think right
yeah passive aggressive yeah behind your
back
we see it as polite
like don't tell someone you hate them
hate them yeah and never let them know
because that would be rude got a lot of
that
stuff it down deep inside
it's where it belongs
um any runaways in the family
runaways is in they ran away and left um
so two of my dad's brothers
uncles sort of
seen how [ __ ] the family was and was
like we're gonna pretend
they they don't really belong to us yeah
we're over here to really nice areas and
then as they've gotten older
they've sort of had regret and tried to
reconnect okay
yeah so not quite run aways but some
people are trying to create a little
space
yeah someone's trying to you know
they're locking their bedroom door
oh that's a good one
um do you have a go-to karaoke song
no do you do karaoke yeah
i will just i'll just go with whatever i
feel like on the ninth how often are you
doing it a year
once
all right a year once a year once is
enough
once
i don't think i've done it in the past
year okay but i think maybe the year
before was twice so that's what's
happening
ah i don't get carrie i just don't get
it now it's brutal it's just fun ah not
to not for me it's yeah i just don't
understand it i mean it's not fun for
anyone else in the room exactly that's
only fun for the person on stage like oh
because you always everyone thinks they
can sing better than they can i that's
not me i i don't think i i know i can't
but the karaoke machines think because
they're always out of key
you're not singing in the the original
key that the song's in so you sound like
steven tyler [ __ ] relax jesus jesus
christ out of key
karaoke i don't know who the sound guy
is
who's producing this
trash you stink um
i think i'm i mean i think i got all the
uh i think i got all the evidence i need
to render a verdict here i got two from
patreon uh guys so as you know when you
sign up for patreon we'll answer your
garbage question on the air it's just
the best way to do it
um this is from double penetration
haven't had one read yet have you ever
left a comment on an internet porn video
no
but i do sometimes want to yeah yeah for
sure like hey jump to four minutes and
15 seconds or something the good stuff
starts with somebody yeah lose the intro
will ya i more like criticism like
shoddy cameraware yeah suck that guy
i caught myself i i could see the boom
guy
i caught myself reading a month like i
like in my head i was like i was like
reading like tweets or something i was
like i'm like what the [ __ ] am i doing
you gotta be some kind of creep
man oh man best one i've ever seen was
this guy's dog [ __ ] and [ __ ] it
also written by toby
it was a home video too
um all right this one's from vaughn is
anyone in your family named tammy
okay no that's an american name oh is it
really yeah tommy's do you have any
aunts or uncles that you call that have
nicknames that's not their real name any
cookies or jojo so my uncle richard is
called pedro
okay
why let's go on another song
him in the guitar
that's my uncle ben it's called barney
but i think that's quite a common
shortening of bernard okay okay yeah
yeah yeah yeah barney's good i like that
barney's nice yeah barney's all right
barney's a good guy
pedro is just pedro to everyone
that's so weird he did something [ __ ]
up
before you kids were born i'll tell you
that right sex tourism
killed a spanish guy
stole his identity
uh
i have a quick one sure so you're our
first uh english guest yeah is there
anything for like future guests second
we had bisping on oh true that was
before my time michael bisping shout out
uh is there anything that that sets you
off where like that's trash that we
should keep our eye out for for future
guests is there like any sort of english
habit that that is instantaneous like
tip for you like this guy's piece of
[ __ ] i think 90 of his life story
yeah anything that his brother's ever
done
you heard about the bird right
you were here for that
dude i still imagine you at 16 be like
ma tell them what happened
i know that i know that feeling of your
two boys being like what the [ __ ]
i thought she was gonna say that he died
and just didn't want to tell you but man
to go in the detail
you picked this feathers out one by one
um wearing a football top
soccer shirt a soccer shirt okay
when you're not playing it yeah so we're
in a football top to the pub
sure same trash really yeah you were
under the games will you wear a
liverpool journey i won't wear it to the
game it's a weird thing with liverpool
fans though it's sort of like what do
you do the scarf or the other maybe wear
a scarf but i won't wear a liverpool top
it's sort of like i i can't really
explain it it's also like it's i think
it's insane
any time we're in a jersey yeah but i
mean people over here will do them to
like a wedding yeah like the people in
like the midwest and stuff because they
that's like the most expensive item of
clothing they own
and it has buttons all like if it's a
baseball jersey it'll have like buttons
on it so they're like well i tried a
knicks jersey on before uh-huh just
because i was like let's see what this
looks like sure and it looked and this
is the right word ridiculous
[Laughter]
yeah so anybody wearing jerseys if you
were designing the opposite of a
basketball player in a lab it looks like
this
it's just a jersey in two years
yeah it looked ridiculous i'm surprised
at that that was a good question to you
but i'm surprised at that wearing a
soccer shirt to a bar is trash yeah huh
cause it's uh it's big here like if
you're going to you're saying to go to
even to watch the game or go like if
you're watching at the pub uh the
american or you're saying just any at
any time
for me yeah anyone wearing a shirt is
trash it when they're not playing the
game for me is like what the [ __ ] are
you doing yeah yeah like if i play so i
play five aside football every now and
then i'll just you know ten of us go for
the game i'll win it then yeah you're
playing
yeah
there was just uh the eagles just played
uh the the washington and when the
quarterback was leaving there was a
bunch of eagles fans on a railing and
they leaned over to say hi to him and
they fell
one of the guys was wearing an eagles
jersey and a helmet
i got a helmet paid off dude
[ __ ] you not
he was wearing a [ __ ] jersey and the
helmet was too big you can't be sitting
in the stands and shoulder pads
that's a tough look it had to be a
little kid i hope it was a little kid
buddy adam rowe 100 trash but what
fantastic such a good one uh you got
anything out you want the folks out
there to know uh lay it on them podcast
is called have a weird it's uh
fun it's me and another co-host who's a
comic and we have guests on every week
and i've got a special on youtube called
club comma which is a 40 minute of stand
up that i put out last year fantastic
buddy thank you so much for coming in
happy birthday happy birthday to you
enjoy new york both of you guys kippy
what do you got for him uh same check
out our special on youtube uh our live
show dates uh
are on sale now go get them uh links
link will be in the description
what was your what's your co-host name
again don nightingale yeah shout out to
dan
uh t-bone we love you buddy um
peace